eine geschichte die man mit es war
einmal eigentliche beginnen müsste es
war einmal ein zukunftsteam von armin
laschet das aber bevor eine zukunft
begonnen hat schon wieder vergangenheit
ist ja ich will sogar heute mich zu der
these hinreisen lassen das zukunftsteam
von armin laschet war fake da
interessiert mich auf eure meinung ich
finde schon ein bisschen merkwürdig also
vor vier wochen werden die dann dahin
gestellt und zelebriert in zukunft der
union und jetzt finden die verhandlungen
gekommen aber ohne das zukunftsteam
stadt also zum beispiel soziale den
sehen wir hier die einzige die
teilnehmen wird ist silvia bär aber der
rest ist eigentlich schon wieder
geschichte und ich lasse mich zu der
these wirklich hinreißen dass das
zukunftsteam fake war also doch wer
mitbestimmt zukünftig auch eine rolle
spielen aber man muss ja das überlegen
ich finde eigentlich das blöde oder ich
finde es eigentlich wirklich falsch von
armin laschet die idee dass ein
bundeskanzler auch alleine nicht starke
so ein team um sich zu schaffen wenn das
ernst gemeint ist finde ich toll aber
eher dem teamgedanken damit ja total
lächerlich gemacht wer so wie wir
stellen uns sehen sagen wir freuen uns
auf bild leib und dann in drei wochen
sitzen dann wieder ganz andere dabei
wieder aber es ist ja ist ja also man
ist ja auch irgendwie ein team und ich
finde das schon wirklich auch wähler
verarsche also sammle rande zur wähler
verarschen zukunft präsentieren und dann
die verhandlungen eigentlich wieder nur
mit der alten garde zu machen aber woran
ist es jetzt genau gescheitert
einfach die alten haben wieder also den
auftrag ist ja zukunft auftrag zukunft
aufbruch aber die alten haben sie halt
wieder durchgesetzt wie er es auch so
auf den parteien ist und man sieht daran
hat dass es zu 15 überhaupt nicht ernst
gemeint war weil wenn das ernst gemeint
gewesen wäre wo ist jetzt zum beispiel
jalloh bei den vereinen verhandlung oder
mit dem sich angela steht ja auch gerne
geschmückt hat war wie gewinnt 25 jahre
alt teil der klima union die völlig
großartig wenn es um einen
zukunftsthemen wir hatten ja auch
familienmitglieder hier beim ersten
studien haben mit ihm gesprochen
ein metallrohr ismus und
sicherheitsexperte natürlich werden
werden auch diese wirklich renommierten
experten für dumm verkauft und die
wähler gleich mit
[Musik]